all right so the new third and probably
final trailer for The Dark Knight Rises
has hit the internet and holy [ __ ] funny
thing you know you expect the final
trailer to be the most exciting one it
is exciting but that's not how it starts
out just starts out really eerie has
that one piano note being pinged over
and over again like some sort of horror
movie involving a big mansion and two
little kids you can hear laughing down
the hallway but you don't see them
because they're ghosts storm coming and
from there the intensity of the trailer
just swells up I love that about this
trailer it was he Catwoman you're like
is she sexy or she playing sexy you
don't know is she Catwoman sexy that's
the question another Anne Hathaway's not
extremely hot she is but I'm just saying
if she Catwoman I'm adaptable but that
little concept is second to a few
different points in the trailer one of
which is that Bane is one formidable son
of a [ __ ] I'm gone from dripping if
someone was in my face saying that I'd
be like yeah okay can I leave please
you're a big guy with a scary voice you
seem to be pretty smart I just want to I
just got to go at a point in the trailer
where you see this you're like okay
people are in trouble
this seems to be the bane everyone
wanted to see on the big screen you know
you saw Batman and Robin your leg all
Bane's a big idiot
oh there that is no he's not he's the
dude it's gonna burn Gotham to the
ground
seriously you see Bane here you get the
feeling everyone's like I'm freaked out
about Bane he scares the living [ __ ] out
of me I want out of the city and Bane's
just always so cool about things you
know he's all walking around I like
horror although I do like his voice
though I can understand him perfectly in
this trailer I really couldn't hit the
first six minutes of The Dark Knight
Rises you know the prologue teaches
your punishment must be more severe I
gotta assume in a few short months I
have become a smarter human being are
they tweaked his voice they said he was
going to tweak his voice but I could
just see being like oh yeah we're
totally gonna tweak his voice oh we
didn't so all you people who can now
understand him is just placebo good job
and a few points in this trailer you get
the feeling Batman might die either
Batman will die or Bruce Wayne will die
yeah it's possible for one to die
without the other I love Barry I've
heard enough members the DeWine family
sees only gonna die you've given them
everything
not everything
see totally gonna die and then at a
point in this trailer as final trailers
do is just an onslaught of awesome in
battle and at the end of this trailer
the bat symbol comes up the title comes
up and just boom again really feels like
it's the end of the end and at the end
of this trailer you see a little bit of
humor and you see that Catwoman is not a
bad person
another warned me about getting into
cars with strange man this just almost
upset Catwoman in this movie had her own
motivation at the beginning like oh yeah
we're totally gonna screw rich people
and then Bane's coming on scene she's
like I don't want that though this is my
speculation but this trailer makes it
look like she's not a complete villain
like the last trailer made her look so
the Dark Knight Rises I'm pumped for
this trailer completely rocks I love the
tone of the trailer if the tone of the
movies like the tone of the trailer I'll
be like yeah Dark Knight Rises so guys
my question what do you think's gonna
happen - Batman is back gonna get broken
is you're gonna dies Bruce Wayne just
gonna hang it up comment below let me
know and as always if you like what you
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you